today I want to talk to you about the
worst question you could ask yourself
I'm Patrick many of your host evalute a
man weakly yes I have a new hairdo shout
out to my friend Natasha for this
haircut but I got a question for you my
wife and I have a debate which one's a
better hairdo do you like this do you
like the older one comment on the bottom
and let me know but let me get right
into the message here so what is the
worst question we can ask ourselves that
we do all the time and what kind of
emotions does it produce goes something
like this you know what if I had a 4.7
GPA in high school and I got a full ride
scholarship to Harvard what would life
look like what if I would have married
my high school sweetheart what if I
wouldn't have married my sweet you know
what if I was a cowboy and I grew up on
this ranch and I wore cowboy hats and I
had this buckle and I spoke like a
cowboy and I won't horseback riding all
the time what would life look like what
would life look like my parents were
multimillionaires and we lived in this
10,000 square foot home I went to
private school you know drove a you know
Maserati to was the coolest cat in
school cuz my parents were so rich I
would have life look like what if my
parents wanted on a divorce and they
would have stayed together what if I
didn't grow up in an environment where
there was war and everything was fine it
was peaceful what if I would have grew
up in an environment that was hostile
would have taught me more toughness you
know what if I would have joined the
military
that would have been pretty interesting
what if I would have been kind of a cop
you know what would have happen what if
I grew up in a family where my mom and
dad were gangsters and I was a thot
myself and you know as a gangster in the
areas well you know what if I grew up in
a mobster family and I ended up becoming
a mobster what would've life look like
you know what if I wouldn't have bought
that business that went out of what if I
would have never bought that one stock
that everybody told me to buy I should
have never bought that stock what would
have had my $173,000 what would have
happened see all those questions have to
do with our gift of imagination
and the gift of imagination is a very
very unique thing we've been given but
it's a very strong weapon if you let it
loose let me explain to you why see
imagination as a negative and it has a
positive and generally the question
starts the same way we start off with
what if I would have married someone
else what if I would have made some
difference what if I would have
different parents what if I was taller
you can never control this because it's
already been made decisions of all we
can do is alarm from it and move on and
make better choices the other kind of
what-if is what if I decide to change my
diet and I lose 30 pounds what will life
look like what if I learned to
communicate better with my family what
if I work harder what if I travel the
world what if I do this positive
imagination possibilities unknown
looking forward to tomorrow looking
forward to waking up in the morning it's
still the same gift of imagination but
you control which side of the
imagination to use so you Marcus
Aurelius who taught stoicism he was the
Roman Empire between 160 180 and 169 AD
many people start out stoicism Seneca
Pittacus but he was mainly known for it
and what he talks about the basic
fundamental of stoicism is this think
about what you can't control and stop
trying to do things that you cannot
control you can't change what you cannot
control see if you're playing poker
you've been dealt a certain hand you got
to play with that hand you can't say I
wish I had a better hand of course we
wish we had a Royal Flush but that's the
hand we got and stoicism is play with
what you currently have today make
better decisions make better judgments
improve and happiness will come from
focusing on what you can't control
instead of focusing on things you cannot
control and if you want to be happy it's
best you focus on things you can't
control
it's my message of the week to you and
please be sure to subscribe to this
channel and comment on the bottom
there's no that's repeated you'll run
fast I have 40 yard